this month marks the 20th anniversary of
the death of Princess Diana she was just
twenty years old when she married Prince
Charles but there were signs of trouble
already in the relationship even before
she walked down the aisle at st. Paul's
Cathedral in London CBS News will
broadcast an encore of our two hours
special it's called a life death and the
legacy of the woman who became the
people's princess here's a look at a
dinner in Buckingham Palace Charles
asked Diana to be his wife they were
really kind of strangers they were only
together 12 times before he proposed to
her 12 times 12 times it was apparent
the newly engaged couple didn't know
each other well in this awkward
televised moment whatever love means
such a thing of course go whatever love
means I mean why go there Diana moved
into Buckingham Palace to prepare to be
a princess but her prince never seemed
to be around and Diana couldn't really
understand this she said why aren't we
spending time together so she was kind
of left to her own devices and during
that time Diana found a bracelet in her
fiance's drawer that he had made for his
ex-girlfriend Camilla so she found this
and she confronted him with it and he
said yes I am giving this Camilla and
I'm gonna and I'm taking it to her and
she was understandably quite furious
this jealousy became a real canker in
the relationship very very early riddled
by insecurity Diana's weight dropped 14
pounds she was having an episode of
bulimia she was it was throwing up the
night before her wedding and Charles he
was crying and there was tears streaming
down his face and his Vallot Stephen
Barry said sir what's wrong and he said
is it possible to love two women at the
same time
the very next day he would be married
and you can see an encore of our CBS
News special Princess Diana her life her
death the truth tomorrow night it airs
at 9:00 8:00 central right here on CBS
I'm still struck that she was only
twenty years old she got married that
they had only seen each other really 12
times and he was 12 years older than her
and in love with another woman who they
were issues before they tied the knot